if climate change were like an animal or
a plant I think it'd be some sort of
parasite because it's the only thing
that's actually growing and getting
bigger while everything else starts
dying off the environment is definitely
very special because if we get rid of it
there's nowhere else we can go like it's
a very one in a million sort of planet
[Music]
a 10 year old some years ago got crossed
with me and said you don't get it he
said you grew up thinking that polar
bears would be there forever
he said I've grown up knowing they will
go extinct I don't remember when I first
became aware about climate change I
don't remember a time where I didn't
know what it was it feels like it's
always been there children are growing
up with this knowledge and this
awareness whereas anyone over the age of
let's say 30 is having to wake up to
this realize it
[Music]
when we asked young people about how
climate change made me feel
three quarters or more I think the
future is frightening so we know that
it's having an emotional impact on
children and young people all around the
world I think climate change is like
really scary and the fact that lots of
people aren't doing much about it just
sort of freaks me out
eight out of 10 told us that people had
failed to take care of the planet so
this is young people and children
looking to adults looking to older
people looking to people in power and
saying why haven't you done something
about this
it makes me feel angry to see such a
clear issue and to see everyone knowing
about this issue and still not doing
anything that they really should be it's
just it's frustrating and I think it's
also tiring to feel so sort of scared
and angry one of the worst things we can
do to children and young people is say
well it's your responsibility now I've
heard this said to Children your
generation will fix this your generation
is so inspiring and creative and
Innovative we're going to leave this to
you to fix there is an idea by older
people that it is sort of on young
people to fix it but I think that's
really unfair and I think it's a
collective responsibility not just not
just on young people not just on me one
of the most worrying statistics was that
48 told us they were dismissed or
ignored when they tried to talk about
climate change
that we could do something about this
afternoon that we could do something
about today in places like school I feel
like they don't really listen and don't
really respect the fact that I've
thought about it and tried to educate
myself about it
I kind of feel really angry and
frustrated because I am actually saying
something meaningful and if you're not
prepared to listen to your children it's
gonna have a big effect because
we actually do have something to say and
we are actually trying to make a change
my advice to adults parents teachers is
do not put it off don't push it away
don't save it up and just have that big
conversation talk about it regularly
that's crucial and it's okay for you to
say to your children I don't have all
the answers
we're not sure exactly how to deal with
all of this but let's find out together
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video